[Music]
we're missed for him here in the quarter
lead pass Kyle pass connection 104 104
he's got over 30 again tonight Maddie
he's got 31 hello gorgeous look how I
write into the NBA Finals 1998 the last
time at this right here G says none of
us get that cabbage any that might be
Jack Wow
you caught that you know what that might
be the early serum season favorite for
your get that garbage out of here is
that line your top five a lot about
serge ibaka ready for that thomas game a
little lip there with a few Jimmy's more
net
[Applause]
Oh Chewbacca saying no no no there it is
again
you're torturing this poor kid Kapus
with a great new look can we go right
here beautiful passing by Davis great
feel for the game that comes out here's
Kyle Lowry
[Applause]
would the reverse
Evan Fournier quickly down the floor
little English on the wall trying to get
the found in but makes a great bucket to
end a half north Philly's finest Pascal
Bogdanovich Jonna packing in
[Applause]
my boozy chef
so I'm finding a vodka where that
thunder of slam 455 left backdoor cut
jeans dozen gold denied my patch Scout
Davis
game is driving the line with the
basketball 2:45 to go what an effort by
Toronto believe this Harrell can't
believe that he goes ugly he's going up
two hands hard and you know ultimately
to the teeth
[Applause]
look at Fred vanvleet operating at tight
quarters hello right there beautiful
pass and mobile back what no man's land
let's help defender Simmons to the
cutting Harris denied
[Applause]
and you know where does it all start the
defensive end looks like an easy to four
hairs at Pascal the second unit
batteries let them in minutes 32 tonight
handle screen a roll right down the gut
hello
strong take that time little two-man
action mid screen a roll and Houston
slow on a help defend his picking that
up
Pascal short and a long rebound and take
it down by Brooklyn there we go
spicy Rice's SIOC the with three blocks
tonight
big time bucket he's got 30
[Applause]
play the Deena wrap this boss
[Applause]
bringing it they force 29 points of 18
Paul did a great job at point guard last
nine years Davis up top with Donna
triple pass
check this out any contact absolutely
absolutely he's allowed into the
frontcourt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I know you better than that the
only thing I ever see you put down is
water or green tea
[Applause]
that's what our note by the way no Paul
that's why Kyle extended his arm
mr. Mary Agnes needed say credits
Grammar School in Brooklyn smack in the
oven at
[Applause]
what's an I'm at eat meat turn to the
corner
I'm talking about my world yes sir
fines OG in a turnover McKinney and
Boucher with the denial check him out
he's going right next to him I just said
ah get it out of here big time block hey
you can see McKinney McKinney in no way
he's gonna get that one over VanFleet
off to miss Detroit gets back but house
he's the same and the slam dunk is
beside himself at an encore
I'm beside myself as a movement by the
Toronto Raptors I mean they just have a
great feel for each other
16-point game 340 to go norm turns the
corner slam dunk over Drummond nasty is
that little hesitation he looked at
Drummond said here you go that's just a
big-time play right and in a pocket just
went to work on the wrong end of it
hello and a break
Pascal Lamy
in search of pocket a guy who's just
utterly brilliant tonight
the game-winner shot faking rebounding
[Applause]
throws it down and we're talking about
making D'Angelo Russell Thompson one hop
of the rappers jumping on that behind
the head over the head pass the
hollis-jefferson from Krebs Ansley lead
106 94 let's go to the board Leah but
that is a big move I think that's bigger
than the jumpy took last year to be
honest to go to being guitar
Fouchet on the rebound slam
this is an incredible dump top state in
2016 and he is ready to cash in
[Applause]
[Music]
von deenis
second play Davis has made a poster are
you kidding me a shot to the cheer slam
dunk contest in Phoenix lodge on of its
and his past stolen away lead pass
wow great catch over the shoulder lays
it up and in and a timeout just porting
this right on the money check this out
what a beauty search shot clock down
Kyle's gonna have to put it up his tie
allowed the last two minutes and Lowry